[Music]
candied fruit and fruit jellies are
Middle Eastern in origin and spread to
Europe around the 12th century this
region of France has been producing them
since the 15th century when wars blocked
access to cane sugar fruit farmers began
planting sugar beets to preserve this
confectionery tradition this company in
France has been catering to people's
sweet tooth since 1880 with its gift
boxes containing traditional candied
fruit and fruit jellies to make candied
fruit ambassador confectioner boils
fresh fruit for many hours to soften the
fibers this process will later help
sugar to penetrate the fruit he pokes
the fruit to see if it's ready boiling
time varies from one hour for apricots
to 8 hours for chestnuts citrus fruits
are sliced before boiling after boiling
the more fragile types of fruit such as
apricots pears and clementines go into
large hot air dehydrators for up to
three weeks every day the master
confectioner replaces the evaporated
water with sugar syrup which
concentrates over time
for less fragile fruits the technique is
different
workers heat them in vats of sugar syrup
for about 10 days the moisture
evaporates and the syrup concentrates
[Music]
the factory cells whole candied fruits
like this collection of clementines
apricots pears figs and plums - gourmet
food shops which sell them by the piece
or an elegant private label gift boxes
[Music]
whole candied fruit are also popular for
designing edible arrangements making
fruit jellies is a different process the
recipe combines fruit pulp making up
more than 50% of the mixture with
powdered sugar liquid glucose a form of
plant sugar pectin to make the mix
gelatinous and natural fruit flavoring a
worker boils down the mix for a half
hour to concentrate the sugar then adds
more fruit flavoring as the mix
continues to cook she draws samples to
measure the sugar content she does this
until the mix hits his target
concentration of 78% another worker
pours the batch from the pot into a
large pitcher then into a square
stainless steel mold it takes the jelly
a day to set once set a worker removes
it from the mold this one's a different
flavor and coats it with crystallized
sugar to preserve it the worker then
lays the jelly square on a cutter the
company calls a guitar because it's
steel wires look like guitar strings the
wires cut once in each direction to make
cubes then another worker applies a
second coating of
in addition to this small batch
production the factory has one automated
machine which makes fruit jellies in a
variety of geometric or fruit shapes
created by templates made of plaster
this process is much faster than the
handmade approach first the machine
makes a bed of starch then it presses
the plaster form into the bed to create
mold cavities
[Music]
the next station fills the cavities with
hot liquid fruit jelly then the moulds
are set aside for a day the starch
absorbs the residual moisture as the
jelly sets the next day workers load the
molds on top of the same machine which
flips them to dump out the jellies the
jellies tumbled down a vibrating
conveyor belt the starch shakes off with
each bounce then they pass under a
spinning brush which removes any
remaining starch the conveyor moves them
into a rotating drum which showers them
with sugar on the packaging line a slow
conveyor belt moves retail boxes in
front of a row of workers each worker is
responsible for a single flavor while
placing the required number of fruit
jellies in the box she also performs a
quality control check removing and
replacing any that are misshapen this
ensures that these traditional fruit
jellies look as good as they taste